so this is one of the home office's some
temporary um pop-up if you like
immigration centers in a town called zhu
zhao in poland which is about an hour
and a half drive uh west of the border
with ukraine
what we've got at the moment is i know
15 people probably waiting outside and
inside 40 to 50 people the home office
say that they are limited with the
number of people who are allowed inside
hence why you've still got
some waiting to go outside now this
is and you'll forgive me you know i've
tried to go through it with various
people and it's pretty confusing and it
is very confusing for people waiting
here but essentially this is where you
can get your biometrics taken
um and copies of uh important documents
like your passport etc and it's the sort
of the next phase to getting a visa
uh to come to the united kingdom
um
but
the next appointment i'm told that you
can get here and you put your
appointments online is the 24th of march
so more than two weeks away we've been
here
45 minutes and i don't think i've seen
anyone exit so
who knows how long the processing system
takes once you're inside but it's not a
quick process
they came they came to the door a moment
ago and suggested that people head to
vaca and said but i've already got
family members there trying to do it
again
being warsaw yeah yeah which is six and
a half hours away yeah it's a long way
away oh it's ridiculously far there's
nowhere near the border it's so they're
suggesting you go up there yeah but
vashta are suggesting we come here
because this is the only one that allows
wall kids so you're told that rashford
warsaw you have to book in an
appointment but the website won't let
you book an appointment
i've tried multiple times and then i
tried to ring there's actually no
contact number for the tls who are the
third party they're not even part or
they're the visa processing
company that you sort of and just be you
are english but you are here trying to
bring some ukrainians out multi european
system
but i had a dear friend in ukraine who i
sorry who can't get help because he's
conscripted at the border and so i said
i'll get your family out and i offered
my home i've opened my finances i
campaigned to allow a sponsorship scheme
and even the sponsorship game even
though they announced it oh we're
accepting 200 000 refugees well here
they are are they being accepted no
the sponsorship still not running
luckily the only reason i can get them
out is they have a sister already
settled in the in the uk so i filled out
all the forms i got all the paperwork
i've translated it all because you can't
even have it in their own native
language so the last thing you're
thinking about when you're playing bombs
what's the last thing you're thinking
about when you're leaving your husbands
when you're leaving your fathers
is abhorrent and it's a failure of a
system and it's
what they're doing
is they're adapting a pre-existing
system so they're taking visa systems
because you can't claim asylum unless
you're on british soil so first of all
you've got to get into britain and that
has to be through a legal process and
that is the visa system so then you're
asked
effectively questions that are for
travel visas almost because that's all
they've done they've just adapted the
system i mean at one point before the
system's even up and running and they
released the new the new paperwork one
of the questions i got asked was when do
they expect to return
when the russians returned to their own
countries what i told the home office
okay
there aren't that many people waiting
outside
let's be honest but it is not moving
quickly
they are very confused for right and for
wrong they are very confused everybody's
spoken to about what is going on what
they're supposed to do and how they're
supposed to get the united kingdom and
all of them have made
by this stage
a very very long and most part
frightening journey just to get here